well speaking of your life which again
has been an amazing one i'm gonna take
you back because next year is the 20th
anniversary of made in manhattan can't
believe it's been 20 years
it's ty what are you talking about ty
don't eat
hello hi
this is christy's got a giant gray dog
i'm gonna go walk with him okay come
with us if your husband wouldn't mind
him she doesn't have a husband i don't
have a husband come on let's go
look i had to google what year made in
manhattan came out
same year that she was dating ben
affleck way back when did you ever get
to meet him with you on set yeah so so
we met him during so when a movie comes
out there's a thing called a press
junket where you go do interviews sit
down in a room in like a hotel room and
you just go from room to room to room
and do a bunch of interviews yeah and he
was with her at that time and he was the
sweetest dude ever i loved him so much
he had the same thing i was like i don't
know what to expect in this guy he's a
huge star why would he have time for me
he was so nice to me man so when you
read like the rest of us that they had
rekindled their whole thing what was
your reaction
great they're both awesome people i
respect the hell out of them and they're
great actors and they're a power couple
all for it
yeah i mean what was your favorite
memory working with j.lo on that film
dude i mean so so
i had worked on previous films when i
was younger and like with some pretty
big people but at that age 10 years old
you really have a full understanding of
who you're working with i knew who jayla
was right i knew how big of a star she
was
and i also knew at that time i'd been
acting long enough to know when people
were going to be like you know diva and
stuff and so she wasn't at all dude she
like taught me so much about how to be a
professional as
an actor that i didn't realize she
taught me until i was older i was like
where did i get these like morals from
and i thought back and i was like jayla
was always on time right always there
the most respectful person and
professional person i'd ever worked with
at the time
so she's awesome dude i love her so much
and i respect her so much i love her i
miss her where are you i was gonna say
do you all keep in touch at all we saw
each other one time i hosted the teen
titans that's right like 2013 14 and she
was there and i danced with her on stage
that was it
[Music]
yo tyler that sound check was killer i
was actually thinking like there's not
gonna be a stage left when you're done
with it i'm stoked for you thanks man
yeah a lot of fun do this what we do you
know
we just blow kids away we just shred we
just read that's it yeah well it is a
big deal because i feel like after the
year that we've had no live shows no
concerts you're back on the road how
does it feel oh it feels great man yeah
like uh so i i started a project with
john feldman and big noise which is what
we're doing here this is the big noise
tour family um and as soon as i started
that project i started releasing stuff
and then cove it happened which i didn't
really have a chance to tour it you know
so a lot of kids have been waiting for
like a couple of years to hear these
songs live so dude very excited come on
so stoked not to mention the fact that
you're at the roxy which i feel like is
one of the most iconic la venues and two
sold out nights back to back yeah it's
pretty great man it's pretty cool it's
pretty great i i also played the roxy
like ten or nine years ago on this same
day shut up yeah to like this thing the
same day get out of here yeah with my
old old band when i was still little
kids yeah i was gonna say this is what
your solo debut right it is yeah all
right drugs the ep is out i mean is it
fair to say that this is probably one of
your most personal and honest pieces of
work yet absolutely yeah every time i
write stuff i always try to be really
transparent and honest when i was
writing this album i was going through
uh sobriety right and overcoming
addiction and so
yeah i'm it's super honest i i've seen a
couple of reviews on twitter from fans
saying hey this is really the song's
really helping me i went through a
similar situation
and i wasn't really looking for that you
know but it's it's it's awesome that i
can like you know
be relatable to people who are going
through the same thing and
you know i was just writing what i knew
and at that moment i knew getting sober
right so was there a part of you that
was almost nervous to drop this because
you are so raw and so honest in it or
did you were you thinking to yourself
this could help someone
yeah definitely more on the ladder you
know i was thinking that this could
probably help someone i wasn't trying to
do that you know but in the back of my
head if there were any nerves which
there weren't but there was a little bit
it'd be like it would be curbed by you
know people could probably get something
from this
you know i just love being honest
because i've been in some weird
scenarios and and people look up to me
sometimes and so they can be like well
if this guy's going through it and he's
doing okay then maybe i can so and for
the first time i feel like there's
there's this unique shared experience
right with the lockdown and the pandemic
and everyone was kind of going through
it i mean what was would you say is the
biggest thing that you learned about
yourself in 2020 um yeah i mean
that i've got some stuff i got to take
care of you know i i never it was weird
i started acting at a really young age
i'm playing music kind of simultaneously
and i always had a career to fall back
on and so when i was dipping around in
like substances and and not really
taking care of myself mentally and
spiritually uh and physically i was like
well i have a career so i can keep going
you know so it was a weird thing so i
realized that i have these issues that i
kind of need to take care of and in
doing that i've realized even more about
myself you know i can talk for hours
about that but yeah man i realized that
like i need to take care of myself more
i can feel the vibe you're in a good
place now would you say that like how do
you feel now absolutely sorry if i spit
on you no
i feel great yeah yeah i feel really
really really good you have a lot to be
happy about i do dude i i've got a great
girlfriend who's coming here tonight and
playing a song with me we she was part
of my single right i'm going on the road
with some of my best friends uh i'm
going on tour and playing music side by
side with some of my best literally this
is just the coolest i'm very happy
there's nothing to be sad about right
now
and even if there is i know how to deal
with it in a more healthy way so you
mentioned your girlfriend i had read
that you had said that she really helped
you to understand that you are queer do
you feel that kind of pressure to you
know
explain to people or explain what you
are
you know i don't i don't feel any
pressure i don't want to like the labels
you know yeah so the labels i think it
gets tricky and people get angry at some
of the things that you know you would
want to call yourself you know because
they'll pick it apart and be like well
you're not this you're not that you know
so i don't really feel like i fit in the
box yeah um so she kind of helped me
realize that i don't fit in the box and
that there isn't a box and there really
isn't a box you know and so that that
was something that should really help me
figure out you know i don't i don't
really want to label myself and i don't
feel like
no matter how i try to explain myself
with it i think somebody's going to try
to pick it apart so i just rather not i
just am honest about who i've been with
and right and what i've done and and
that has had some sort of effect on
people whether it's good or bad i just
i'm like look i'm honest here's what
i've done who here's who i've done it
with i'm not gonna label myself you can
if you
[Music]
it
want
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
has that been tough on you at all kind
of like living really growing up in the
future yeah it was it you know i do my
best to kind of stay on the outskirts
and not invest myself too much into the
public eye
um but it's still i'm still in it
whether i like it or not and so it has
affected me there have been moments like
when the height of teen wolf happened
that i didn't want to do it anymore
right right i like i want to live in a
skate shop and and live in a private
suburb town my whole entire life and so
this is it's a new thing but i've
learned how to deal with it and use it
to my advantage and try to spread some
sort of good message
[Music]
[Music]
you